Isaiah is with us in Columbus Ohio hi
Isaiah how are you hi Dave how are you
better than I deserve what's up same
here you're kind of on a constant loop
in our home my daughter calls the Uncle
Dave so someone to know we watched that
a lot and one of the shows someone said
something about alpacas and at the time
you laugh and thought it was pretty
funny apparently but I just wanted to
know since my wife and I were saving up
and working to start our own ranch and
raise alpacas I want to know if you knew
something that I didn't and maybe I
should change course or something I
don't even remember what you're talking
about but I guess I can come in oh now
practice I was trying I think we were
talking about emus weren't we I believe
it was broke several years ago because
there was this emu fad and a bunch of
people bought emus and then there was
there supposed to be this huge demand
for the meat and it was basically a
bunch of crap there was no demand for
emu meat and pretty soon the people just
had Eddie Muse everywhere but you know
alpacas I mean I know I'm not an expert
on our Packers I'm not even an expert on
branches but from a business perspective
I think you're entering a pretty narrow
market agreed yeah and you better really
know your stuff and you better really do
this you can't do it just because you
read in some article about our Packers
are making people rich because they're
not I mean any more than any more than
cows are making people rich cows make
people pretty poor all the time and some
of them they make people rich but it's
as do it running a business called
cattle you know and it's a business and
when it ceases to be a business that
starts to be a fad or never becomes a
business because all it is is a fad then
there you go so what is the deal what do
you want what do you get out of our
Packers what's the end product the end
product is the fleece you can excuse me
you can turn into sweaters and
and so forth very similar to Kashmir in
the quality of police and there you can
also breed and/or sell them and show
them and all that but it's almost
completely about the fleece and the big
part of it is its hypoallergenic and
stuff so with everybody that has
allergies my my children for example
have allergies and are you aware in that
have you been in agriculture and
ranching before no this would be my
first venture into it so why we have our
first venture into ranching and with a
very narrow product line well that is
actually the second half of it
the first stockpile be starting with his
goats and I've my I don't have all of
the expertise myself it's a good friend
of mine who does and we're gonna be
working together and has made lots of
money on now Packers and goats not
alpacas is that different thing but the
goats they did in their native country
yes okay all right well I mean it sounds
like you're going into something you're
in experienced in and obviously I'm
going to tell you don't borrow money to
do it
I was never of money you may put into
this may go away
as you you know from a business
perspective you just got a very narrow
demand product line that the general
public is not aware of and so it's not
like you're you know cowhides leather
obviously would be a completely
different thing a broad market for that
and or wool obviously there's a broad
market for that and so forth but if
you've studied the market and you
understand whose thing I don't want to
just trust a guy who once raised and
they'll pack I halfway around the world
and his family did that for two
generations or something that's that is
a bad idea I mean you're in the United
States and you think about you need to
understand exactly how this is going to
turn into money and how the like likely
it is because you're talking about a
business here you can't get enamored
with hypo-allergenic narrow market stuff
because your kids have dollar
that's a good way to lose all your money
so you need to look at the business
aspect of this where does this turn into
money and what how many steps does it
take to turn into money and how much
money does it turn into and how likely
is it to turn into money and because it
scares the crap out of me you're in a
really narrow market a fad like market
and it sounds like you've got a guy from
another country who has come along and
told you goats and alpacas worked in
another market in another country and
now you think they're going to work in
Columbus Ohio I just I don't know again
I'm not an expert but it just sounds
weird so I would want to know a whole
lot more about it if somebody brings
something in here that feels weird to me
usually I find out the reason it felt
weird because it was weird and so you
just kind of got to get down into it and
go okay what's the problems with this
what am I not seeing what are my blind
spots and really study it because
otherwise every dollar you're putting at
risk here could be gone